how scum resumes Peter Pan welcome to
five nights at Freddy's 2 aka
YouTube views cash-grab 2014 I don't
understand why this is so [ __ ]
popular I just if he wasn't really that
excited for this game hit that like
button if this video gets 60,000 I'll
upload part two right away and we'll see
how it goes I am excited to try it out
and see what he took from the first game
to improve in the second one maybe
there's some cool new secrets that
awaits this I don't know it's but we're
about to say are they twitching they
look really cute I'm sorry I kind of
wanted to take them home and [ __ ] them
cuddled up let's play
she flipping me off oh it's a cupcake
I told she's flipping me off through the
cupcake what a [ __ ]
grand reopening come be part of the new
phase of Freddy's fazbear's pizza and it
starts at while I am first night
fan-fucking-tastic are you boys excited
for this title can we talk about how hot
the chicken is what a chick am i right
oh it alerts me what's going on why is
it alerting
what am I supposed to do Oh
check the light oh my god that's pretty
cool I lit up the rooms baby Part A Part
A I'm training my flashlight though what
what what do you want for me there's
nothing in there no am I like I cute
they are they're [ __ ] the door it
looks yes boobs how can I be scared of
that
Oh what okay so this one is in here I
don't really see it though I hear a
bunch of [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] get it
oh no he died he was shocked y'all wind
up music box yay but does that calm them
down or some [ __ ] oh hi there fella
there's so [ __ ] cute
just want to make out with him is that
is that it then I click the make up and
make out simulator ah freak died of it
what the [ __ ] oh my god what what what
did i do huh
well [ __ ] now I gotta listen to that old
[ __ ] again because I got jump scared
spooked goddamnit
hey I can wear a mask now at least yay
I had the Freddy mask that's kind of
cute does that protect me
I guess I have to disguise myself as one
of them maybe that's the cake oh look I
waited four minutes and absolutely
nothing happened
I love it best game best game ever
I have played my laughs oh I heard
something
he moved oh my god he moved where a
table hey number seriously where is he I
don't [ __ ] see him alright well I
wind up the music box clicking on there
you go so why not for you now where is
that [ __ ] I know him boys phases out
that's that's a day who are you playing
the guitar brother sweet soul brother
he's playing nightwish that did it
editor dead that's an anguish dammit
dead dead dead dead dude to think it's
hard here maybe
I could do this all night long baby girl
I just wanna rock your world with my
girl I don't know I don't know the music
box so I have to keep going and grind up
the music box do I have the worst job in
the world or wine
what are you doing take that cupcake
somewhere else
damn it chicken you're not supposed to
be in a chicken your [ __ ] cat way you
though I'll give you that I like the
style of the game I'll get I'll give him
that
it's kind of cool like I want to make
out with him so much you guys really
don't move huh
so I guess what happens when they I see
them here is that I put this on oh oh oh
am I gonna get spooked now the chicken
I'll chicken what are you doing that
chicken piece of chicken piece of
chicken
all right we're fine chickens they're
okay Gracie
okay yes chickens there you're there
chickens there you're there
chicken stared you're there check it
there you're dead you're so cute girl
wait maybe I should know
chicken stared damn it damn it
Oh your leg he's so [ __ ] cute I want
to film you guys more but it's just too
cute too cute for me I [ __ ] love it I
[ __ ] look where's where's the last
guy damn it oh I'm wearing the hat I'm
wearing the Hat don't spook me bro all
right we need to charge the music box
for some [ __ ] reason it's kind of
like charging a pacman
what are you doing there brother Oh God
hey it's me your friend hey what's up
all right we actually survived holy [ __ ]
all right
where are the rest of those [ __ ] I
don't know you are all right well it was
the chicken [ __ ]
I was Freddy where is mrs. chicken
where's miss chicken nuggets hey if I
don't see miss chicken nuggets soon I'm
gonna get real away where's [ __ ]
Smith's chicken nuggets hey damn brother
where's chicken nuggets chicken eyes
wait that's not a very nice sound
Bank may charge that [ __ ] oh I did it
hallelujah place them oh sorry
we're dead I make one completed all
right she pressed one more check out the
link in the description leave it like if
this video gets how many do you think
your boys can handle eighty all right
eighty for the next video see you in the
next one stay awesome browse